los incendios de la costa oeste no sólo
están arrasando cientos de miles de
hectáreas también están polarizando a la
clase de política por ejemplo trampa
segura que estos incendios se deben
principalmente a la mala gestión de las
zonas boscosas mientras que otros
políticos sobre todo de corte liberal
aseguran que estos incendios se deben
principalmente al cambio climático pero
lo cierto por ahora es que hay casi 2
millones de hectáreas que han sido
arrasadas en estos mega incendios en los
estados de oregón california y
washington tan sólo en california hay 29
grandes incendios que arden casi sin
control mientras que en oregón son 5
mega incendios los que carbón ethan el
estado ahora mismo los bomberos miles de
bomberos que están desplegados en estos
tres estados trabajan desesperadamente
por controlar los incendios y también se
puede ver aquí otra otra de las
consecuencias de estos fuegos es
principalmente el denso humo y las
cenizas que hacen el aire casi
irrespirable sobre todo en california